[Music]
on average our hearts beat 1.3 times
they pump 6.3 liters of blood around the
body
four babies are born worldwide and two
people die to a human a single second
is not a very long time
and yet
in the entire universe
our planet travels 220 kilometers in
orbit around the center of the galaxy
our sun loses about a million tonnes of
its mass out into space
4800 new stars are born in the milky way
and across the observable cosmos just
under 1 000 supernovae
entire star systems
to smithereens
a lot can happen
in one second
but is it enough time
to build a universe
the smallest fraction of time by which
we measure our lives the second can
trace its origins through thousands of
years of human history as early as the
23rd century bc the ancient sumerian and
babylonian civilizations devised a
system of counting based on the
supremely divisible number 60. later the
egyptians favored the practicality of
the number 12 as the number of finger
joints on a single hand that could be
counted with the thumb our modern
concept of time is thus built upon these
cultural preferences
atomic clocks the universal standard for
measuring time on earth and in space
define a second as 9 billion one hundred
and ninety two million six hundred and
thirty one thousand seven hundred and
seventy radiation pulses of an
irradiated cesium 133 atom
as an ultimate definition it is accurate
precise
but inelegant
it is a reflection of our history our
perception of time space and matter
but one second seems impractical when
considering the history of the cosmos as
a whole
indeed on a cosmic scale our universe
has clocked up some
436 quadrillion seconds so far
and those seconds can also contain
almost incomprehensible vastness
in 2020 scientists in the german
electron synchrotron in hamburg
bombarded hydrogen atoms with x-rays
knocking electrons free from their
orbits and sending them skipping to the
adjoining atom as the speed of light is
the fastest you can go and hydrogen is
the smallest molecule there is the time
it took for this to happen was and is
the shortest fraction of time ever
measured in an experiment
that time was 247 zeptoseconds or nearly
250 billionths of a trillionth of a
second
there are 2
500 times more zeptoseconds in a single
second then there have been seconds
in the history
of the universe
and so as we peer back through the eons
glimpsing the universe's childhood from
distant and ancient starlight and
reconstructing its growing pains in
powerful particle accelerators
we uncover
a surprising truth
one second is more than enough time
to build
a universe
for most of its existence our cosmos has
looked surprisingly like it does today
stars have lived and died galaxies have
formed spun and collided space has
calmly expanded and cooled
but our universe did have a beginning a
period of wild revolutionary change
assembling an orderly cosmos from
practically nothing at all
though a single second seems barely long
enough to accomplish the ultimate act of
creation as we shall see the briefest of
moments to our human eyes can be an
eternity from a different perspective
and incredibly we can draw a clear line
back from our vast present cosmos to the
miraculously perfect mix of raw
ingredients that came into being in that
first moment
so just how recognizable is our universe
when just a single second has passed
is the cosmos we see and feel around us
already inevitable
and with 436 quadrillion seconds to
choose from across 13.8 billion years
could it really all come down
to the first one
across the earth a cyber attack happens
once every 39 seconds which is once
every 39 trillion billion zeptoseconds
or 2 200 times a day nordvpn has been
kind enough to sponsor this video and
they are a premium choice to help
maintain a wall around your data a vpn
is like a tunnel that keeps your data
private and protected whether you're out
and about in a coffee shop or at home
nord is also the fastest vpn there is
and has over 5 400 servers in 60
countries especially useful if you want
to buy discounted games in different
countries or access international
netflix or hbo for example i was able to
watch the recent matrix film even though
it wasn't available in spain where i
live it wasn't great but i was able to
find cosmos too which was fantastic
so to help support history of the
universe and try out nord with a 30 days
money back guarantee head over to
nordvpn.com forward slash hot u
thanks
this is the united states national radio
quiet zone
this 34 000 square kilometer patch of
land stretches across three states and
two mountain ranges in the eastern u.s
and demarcates a region of eerie silence
from radio transmission wi-fi signal and
cell phone service
and the green bank observatory in west
virginia sits at the heart
of this oasis of calm
the exclusion of all earthly sources of
radio noise makes green bank the best
place in the world to listen closely to
the stars and for the last 65 years the
site has been associated with the
headline grabbing search for
extraterrestrial intelligence
and in 2012 the immense steerable radio
telescope detected a signal that made
astronomers sit up and take notice
coming from a point more than 4 500
light years away in the giraffe
constellation a high-speed pulsing
signal pierced to the west virginian
radio silence
it was loud and persistent
but it was not
aliens
the signal was in fact coming from a
rapidly spinning and incredibly dense
ball of stuff
it
was a neutron star whirling around its
axis 346 times a second emitting a
stream of radio noise that intersected
with earth and the green bank telescope
over and over again astronomers named it
poetically psr
j0740
the star weighed in at around 2.1 times
the mass of our sun but all of that mass
was crammed into a ball that was just 27
kilometers in diameter making psr
j0740 the most massive neutron star ever
discovered constructed from the densest
material in the universe
a neutron star is the corpse left behind
when a gigantic star reaches the end of
its life
when the heat from fusion is no longer
enough to keep the star inflated the
core collapses under immense
gravitational forces in the hydrogen and
helium atoms left over in that core the
pressure is enough to squeeze electrons
and protons together on a subatomic
level creating a formless paste of
neutrons with no empty space between
them weighing 10 trillion kilograms per
cubic centimeter
a single spoonful of neutron star would
weigh as much as 8
500 great pyramids of giza
but the upper bounds on neutron star
densities are still unexplored
such high gravitational pressures are
impossible to replicate in a lab on
earth but indirect measures and
theoretical models can give us an idea
gravitational waves radiating out from
huge space-time distortions are the
echoes of catastrophic events too
distant in time or space for us to
observe
from these we have found evidence for
colliding neutron stars up to 2.2 times
the mass of our sun and at much higher
masses around three times the mass of
our sun a collapsing star core won't
form a neutron star at all but will
rather compress
into a black hole
their impossibly dense interiors are
forever beyond the reach of our
instruments and so their formation and
structure remain a mystery
for now
in this way probing the densest objects
in the universe mirrors the challenges
of probing the formation of the universe
itself
[Music]
as we push the limits in size mass and
density our tools and models become
increasingly inadequate to describing
the bizarre conditions and phenomena
scholars are forced to construct a
theoretical house of cards based first
on what we do know then what we think we
know and finally what seems
statistically most probable
the further we push into the hearts of
neutron stars or reach back into the
earliest moments of the cosmos the
taller and more precarious that delicate
construction becomes
mathematics is built upon mathematics
and at any point a single observation or
flaw in logic could bring the whole
house tumbling down
and so
the universe began
436 quadrillion seconds ago
with a bang
or perhaps it didn't
it certainly began but the nature of
that beginning is still a subject of
debate to put it mildly
did the cosmos germinate explosively
from the seed of a singularity or bounce
from a preceding universe with a brutal
crunch leaving whatever came before our
time and space forever out of reach or
was it born in a hypothetical
multi-dimensional hyperspace our
precious universe little more than a
collision of lower dimensional membranes
impossible to discern due to our limited
perception of cosmological geometry
at the very beginning at the top of the
theoretical house of cards all
possibilities
are equally bizarre
fortunately from this intangible moment
onwards things can only improve although
it will be some time yet before our
universe looks or behaves how we might
expect it is at least a tangible
three-dimensional entity
the arrow of time has begun its flight
as the unstoppable march of entropy
takes hold dividing the smallest
distance in nature the plant length by
the fastest speed known the speed of
light you arrive at planck time
the smallest possible fraction of time
in our universe is a septillionth of a
zeptosecond
and when a single planck time has passed
the universe
is very
very strange
the entire cosmos is just a plank length
long time is undefined and space is
ultimately compactified at this
minuscule quantum scale weirdness rules
space-time itself is folded and meshed
into itself in this state which has been
described as a quantum foam microcosmos
spanning wormholes and primordial black
holes spontaneously appear and disappear
without any apparent cause and effect it
is impossible to pinpoint what this
planck error universe really looked like
as statistically it is the average of
all possible geometries
nothing makes sense or even gives a clue
to how things might change
but things
do
change
the primordial heat and energy of the
newborn cosmos begin to drop and for
about a quadrillionth of a zeptosecond
the mysterious force of gravity is now
manifest in a way that we can understand
it but there is still no matter in the
universe only knotted and tangled energy
fields which for now are
indistinguishable today the strong weak
and electromagnetic forces rule our
lives and the interactions of all matter
in the cosmos but during this so-called
grand unification epoch they are
combined into a single unified
electro-nuclear force
we cannot say for certain how such a
consolidated cosmos might have looked
but without anything free to yet act
upon the question is perhaps immaterial
cooling continues and the strong nuclear
force is the first to break free from
its brethren the sudden split is enough
to spawn a new generation of stuff in
the universe as the messengers of the
new strong force gluons spring into
existence alongside something entirely
new the first particles of true
matter
but the emergence of the strong force
also triggers another event one which
will come to shape the universe and our
experience of it
suddenly after 10 quadrillionths of a
zeptosecond of existence the cosmos
inflates
it grows at a spectacular exponential
rate doubling in size more than 90 times
in a hundred billionth of a second
in a flash the universe increases its
volume by a factor of 10 to the power of
78. the random quantum fluctuations that
ruled in the planck-sized universe were
suddenly inflated to tangible size
freezing energy variations in place that
would come to define the large-scale
structure of the cosmos but at the same
time space expanded so much so fast that
the local confines of our observable
universe was set and would forever
exclude distant potentially exotic parts
of the cosmos as a whole
with inflation completed a trillionth of
a zebuto second after it began the new
larger and matter-filled universe
continues to expand but at a more
stately pace gluons of the strong force
intermingle with mata and antimatter
particles that arise spontaneously from
photons many of these pairs are destined
for destruction however annihilating
together to turn back into photons
in this way the universe has yet to
decide exactly what
it will be filled with and it is too hot
for anything to stick around for long
expansion continues a single zeptosecond
ticks by and then another and then a
billion more
finally the temperature and energy of
the universe drops enough for the
electro weak force to split
like a spinning coin on a table with one
side indistinguishable from the other it
slows and eventually settles with heads
and tails distinct
the electromagnetic force and weak
nuclear force as we know them today
become distinct
more varied particles begin to emerge
we enter an age of matter over energy
and the material seeds of our universe
a sown
the universe is still much hotter and
much more energetic than it is today but
it has finally reached a level that is
within the realms of our most powerful
instruments
using vast particle accelerators we can
simulate the conditions of the universe
a billion zeptoseconds in
we have reached the lower stories of our
theoretical house of cards and we can
begin to say with certainty how the hot
cosmic soup behaved
through those billion or so zeptoseconds
of the early universe only the smallest
fundamental particles could hold their
shape and even then not for long in a
cooler cosmos gluons have the power to
combine triplets of quarks together to
form protons and neutrons but at this
early time although both quarks and
gluons exist it is still too hot for
them to unite so free quarks and
antiquarks spring into existence float
around freely for a while and then
collide and obliterate one another in a
shower of photons again as temperatures
drop leptons like electrons and
positrons also enter the fray but it
will be a long time before they settle
down a few more trillion zeptoseconds
pass and the expanding cosmos cools
fewer spontaneous particle births take
place and gluons can finally combine
quarks into larger composite hadrons
bringing many of the antimatter
collisions and annihilations to an end
depending on the quark ingredients the
gluons help to build protons neutrons
and other more exotic hedgerons along
with their antimatter counterparts
[Music]
and so after a billion trillion
zeptoseconds a single second has passed
the cosmos is filled with matter the raw
building blocks of everything we see
today
our observable universe is now about 20
light years across
the entire cosmos is as similar to the
heart of a neutron star as it will ever
be it is hot
super dense and filled with
hyper-compressed matter quite unlike
anything we see elsewhere or have seen
since
for the neutron star there is no going
back the simplicity of its interior
leaves no room for escape from the
crushing gravity and the gradual
interminable cooling
but the universe after one second
is full of potential
all the matter and energy and feels and
particles that will create the cosmos we
see today
for the second old cosmos
the skies
the limit
but
there are many ways to build a universe
the events that take place as the first
second tick spy will prove to be pivotal
to the way our cosmos evolves despite
the bounty of its frantic first
zeptoseconds and the many quadrillion
seconds still to come the universe's
destiny is in the hands of physics at
this very moment
just how differently could things have
turned out
[Music]
on april fool's day 1948 the scientific
journal physical review published a
paper that would end up making history
for the wrong reasons
phd student ralph alpha had spent the
last year developing his ideas for how
the universe's chemical elements came to
be along with his supervisor george
gamau at the john hopkins university in
maryland
but as the paper was finalized gamau
spontaneously invited the eminent
physics professor hans beeta to
co-author the finished paper even though
he'd not contributed to the work at all
the sole purpose of this mysterious move
was to complete a greek alphabet
ortholist
and alpha beta and gammas origin of
chemical elements became known as the
alpha beta gamma paper
or more simply the alphabetical article
alpha perhaps justifiably was not amused
beta had been happy to add his input to
further discussions but when the theory
founded in the face of new data he
reportedly considered changing his name
to zacharias
alpha's hijacked theory was a relatively
simple one he supposed that all of the
chemical elements that are in existence
today were assembled in the earliest
moments of the universe through the
successive capture of neutrons making
larger and larger atomic nuclei his
calculations showed how the increasing
energy needed to make each element could
account for the modern day abundances of
the elements namely that the lighter
atoms are much more numerous than their
heavier cousins it was a reasonable
theory for the time and the maths held
up but a problem soon emerged
out of all the elements that have been
discovered and documented none of them
have an atomic mass of five or eight
there is helium with a mass of four
lithium with a mass of seven and
beryllium with a mass of nine
but nothing in between
these missing masses posed a big problem
for alpha's stepwise elemental assembly
you can't climb a staircase one step at
a time if two of the steps are missing
so there must be another explanation
[Music]
in trying to understand how our modern
universe was made it first helps to know
what the universe is made of
there are 92 elements that occur
naturally on earth each with a unique
number of protons in their atomic nuclei
and some with slightly variable numbers
of neutrons giving rise to various
isotopes of varying long-term stability
the smallest and simplest is hydrogen
comprising just a single proton while
the heaviest is uranium-238 with 92
protons and 146
neutrons
looking beyond earth astronomers and
planetary scientists have spent
centuries examining the compositions of
the moons other solar system planets
meteorites our sun other stars in our
galaxies and the exoplanets that orbit
them gas clouds and nebulae as well as
distant galaxies and intergalactic dust
their goal is to establish what they are
made of and by extension what comprises
the universe as a whole and the ultimate
conclusion bolstered by new discoveries
every day is that the basic ingredients
are the same
there are only these 92 naturally
occurring elements
wherever we look
but there is plenty of variation in how
these elements are distributed on a
relatively local scale our sun hogs much
of the hydrogen and helium in the solar
system although plenty of hydrogen is
also to be found in icy water around the
system's outer edges and in the gas
giants that lurk in the shadows heavier
elements tend to collect closer to the
star providing the building blocks for
solid rocky planets like earth venus
and mass
but there are also patterns to be found
on a galactic scale
the closer an interstellar traveler
strays to the center of the galaxy the
more of the heavier elements they will
encounter and if they should visit a
long-lived star like a cool burning red
dwarf they would notice a relative
paucity of heavier elements with a
corresponding lack of rocky planets in
orbit around them
piecing together the clues in these
galactic patterns it becomes clear that
the abundances of the elements are
intrinsically linked to the births and
deaths of stars
in the center of the galaxy where
gravitational forces are most intense
mata is churned into a turbulent dense
mass constantly warped and twisted into
collapsing knots
stars are crushed into existence as
fusion ignites bright points of light
that burn hot and fast before dying
spectacularly and seeding the roiling
clouds once again
here stars live fast and die young
recycling their fuel time and time again
over several billion years
in contrast long-lived red dwarfs burn
slow and cool often in the outer karma
reaches of the galaxy born long before
frantic stellar living and dying took
place their compositions are an
invaluable window into what things were
like in the galaxy's earlier years
drawing conclusions from this stellar
testimony we see that the heavier
elements owe their existence not to a
gradual neutron assembly at the
beginning of time as ralph alpha posited
but rather to the ongoing processes
inside stars
and ironically it was hans beta who
continued this train of thought
throughout the 1950s and 1960s building
on the parallel research into nuclear
fusion to consider the energy sources
inside stars
he spent these decades devising
mathematical models to describe how most
of the heavy elements could be assembled
in their hot dense cores from the simple
building blocks of hydrogen and helium
this process of stellar nucleosynthesis
proved robust even after some 50 years
of advancing astronomy and in 1967 hans
beta the cuckoo in the alphabetical
article nest was alone awarded the nobel
prize in physics for his theories
stellar nucleosynthesis sees everything
from lithium to uranium forged in the
hearts of stars or during their
inevitable catastrophic destruction but
what it doesn't explain is how the
lightest elements hydrogen and helium
came to be in the first place
and in fact while the alpha beta gamma
paper may have been wrong about most of
our elements
it may just have been onto something
with the lighter ones
the raw ingredients for everything in
the universe must have already been in
place before the first stars were born
so they must owe their creation to an
entirely different process
one that was shaped by the state of the
universe
in its very first second
[Music]
in the clear morning light the bear
windswept summit of mauna kea is adorned
with a necklace of smooth white domes
each is a huge observatory housing some
of the most important telescopes in the
world today
all of which take advantage of the
uniquely clear view that the hawaiian
volcano's position affords the air above
mauna kea is exceptionally dry allowing
astronomers to see stars galaxies and
nebulae with better precision than
almost anywhere else on earth scientists
squabble and scramble for invaluable
time with one of the 13 telescopes that
crown the volcanic massif each hoping to
find the answers to their own cosmic
mysteries in the crisp hawaiian sky
so it was that in 2013 three american
astronomers used the powerful 10 meter
wide keck telescope to discover
something surprising with the telescope
pointed towards the constellation of leo
they had been searching for quasars
these bright star-like objects are
thought to be extremely luminous
galaxies that were common during the
universe's first billion years or so
but before they could find what they
were looking for the astronomers spotted
something else
something which was blocking their view
a cloud of gas
too dim to be visible to the naked eye
but easily spotted by the powerful keck
and by measuring how much the clouds
faint light had been stretched and
redshifted by the expansion of space
they calculated that it lay some 11.6
billion light years away from the earth
of course the further we appear into the
distant reaches of space the further
back in time we can see in addition to
probing the atmospheres of exoplanets
the new james webb telescope will also
turn its instruments to the farthest
light it can possibly find and so the
light from these distant clouds had
traveled
11.6 billion light years meaning that it
must have departed 11.6 billion years
ago
when the universe was a little under 2
billion years old
we have seen stars and galaxies at this
distance dating from this time so we
know that the universe's age of
starlight was in full swing but when the
astronomers scanned the cloud to
determine its composition they found a
puzzling simplicity
these clouds contained only hydrogen
and helium
gas clouds are no great novelty in the
universe as a whole they are scattered
within and between galaxies and contain
within them the scattered remnants of
long dead stars the fusion within these
stars creates heavier elements of carbon
oxygen even iron and when they die they
seed the space around them with the
ingredients for making new stars as well
as the rocky planets and moons that come
to orbit them but these mysterious new
clouds contained none of that
to remain uncontaminated by anything
heavier than a helium atom they must
have never witnessed the birth and death
of stars never been ignited by stellar
fusion
it was then the astronomers realized
that they were in fact pristine relics
of the universe as it was just one
second after the big bang
when all around them had been pushed and
pulled chemically reforged and
redistributed these tiny patches of
space had managed to escape
today as their light reaches the
magnificent keck telescope on the summit
of mauna kea they helped to paint a
picture of the universe when it was just
one second old
[Music]
from an unimaginably hot indistinct and
energetic soup the second old universe
is now a moderate 10 billion degrees and
measures several light years across
it is filled with the victors of
particle battles along with the photon
shrapnel of countless mutually
destructive encounters
those particles which possess mass today
are already endowed with it thanks to
the higgs field the four fundamental
forces strong weak electromagnetic and
gravity are in full and comprehensible
operation although their behavior in
this hot and energetic firmament is
quite different to today
and it was in this moment about one
arbitrary human second in
something happened that would set the
stage for all that was to come
something that would lead directly to
the creation of hydrogen and helium
clouds like the ones spotted from the
summit of mauna kea
and would indirectly come to shape the
evolution of the entire cosmos
[Music]
in august 1868 the indian town of guntor
near the country's eastern coast
swelters under the growing heat of the
morning sun
french astronomer pierre janssen sweats
beneath his wide-brimmed hat as he
fusses about his instrument watched at a
respectful distance by a crowd of
curious locals adults and children alike
peer along the instrument's heading
wondering what the scholar could
possibly hope to gain from pointing his
telescope directly at the blazing sun
they consider the very real possibility
that the sweating frenchman is quite mad
but janssen is not mad indeed he has
traveled for a month covering nearly 6
000 miles from his home in paris
specifically to be in this very position
at this very moment
shading his eyes he risks a quick glance
at the sun and sees with satisfaction a
tiny nibble into its edge
for janssen is a 19th century eclipse
chaser
and the main event has just begun
as the shadow of the moon creeps across
the face of the sun the late morning air
becomes noticeably and eerily cooler
cows moo in the pastures and birds dart
restlessly from tree to tree
the animals are unsettled
but yanson
is in his element
with a final tweak the telescope and its
accompanying spectroscope is in place
just in time for the moment of totality
day turns to night and in the sky above
a ring of bright light is all that's
left of the scorching star's light
the sun's corona projects past the
moon's shadow and yanson now cool calm
and collected makes quick and accurate
notes of what his spectroscope reveals
spectroscopy was relatively new to
science at the time of janssen's
expedition but it already proved a
valuable tool for identifying specific
chemical compounds in any emitted light
chemicals emit or absorb very specific
wavelengths of light so in a complete
spectrum they leave behind a fingerprint
of lines particular to that compound
spectroscopy is such a powerful tool in
fact that it is still being used in some
of the most advanced astronomical probes
today indeed the james webb space
telescope will search the atmospheres of
exoplanets with its spectroscope looking
for fingerprints characteristic of life
like gases like oxygen and methane
yanson is already familiar with the
spectral fingerprint of many of the
compounds on earth sodium hydrogen and
many more have already been studied in
depth
but during this eclipse in india the
astronomer feels a flush of excitement
as he sees a pattern that he has never
seen before
[Music]
a bright line close to the fingerprint
for sodium but different enough to merit
its own classification
it doesn't match the spectrum of any
known element and so he concludes
it must represent something new lurking
out there in the sun's corona
the line is bright enough that it could
be seen even after the moon's shadow
passes and janssen's observations are
confirmed by english astronomers just a
couple of days later they name this new
abundant alien element helium
after the greek word for the sun
if helium was indeed a new element then
its method of discovery was very
irregular and many other scientists were
skeptical how likely was it really that
an element could be so abundant out
there in space and yet have evaded
detection on earth
today helium is best known for its use
in party balloons but it has also become
an invaluable part of our modern lives
the inert gas is lighter than air and
has an exceptionally low boiling point
making it essential to high-tech
industry and medical science
this is because fortunately in the early
days of the 20th century prospectors in
oil fields around dexter kansas struck
gaseous gold when they found the
unreactive element mixed in among the
more expected natural gas reserves
it transpired that the same geological
wrinkles that worked to trap oil and
methane beneath the surface also
captured helium
but even this federal reserve is finite
to date every source of helium on earth
has been found by accident and those
sources are beginning to run dry we
consume 140 billion liters of helium
every year and with no easy way to find
more when we run out
unless it is trapped by geological
flukes most of earth's helium simply
floats out to space which explains why
it was so difficult to detect here in
the first place
the gas's paucity on earth is made all
the more painful by its spectacular
abundance in space
helium is the second most abundant
element in the entire universe making up
around 25 percent of all the atoms in
existence today and second only to that
of hydrogen and remarkably scientists
believe these cosmic abundances were
baked into the universe some 13.8
billion years ago when the cosmos
was just one
second
old
it is these abundances that drove the
creation of stars planets and life and
if it weren't for a seemingly
insignificant quirk of particle physics
then solar systems galaxies and the
entire universe could have followed a
very different path
after a trillion billion zeptoseconds or
one full second the cosmos has been
filled with matter but that matter is
still behaving strangely protons and
neutrons have been created by the
binding of quarks but in this hot
particle soup the hyperactive weak force
nudges the hadrons to switch identities
with a helping hand from free floating
electrons and positrons protons become
neutrons and neutrons become protons and
while the temperature is sufficiently
high the reactions balance each other
out so there are approximately equal
numbers of each
but at one second the temperature of the
cosmos drops far enough for the weak
force to lose its potency the identity
switching reactions slow down and
eventually stop in a process known
dramatically as freeze-out
but the universe at this point is by no
means cold it is still 10 billion
degrees on average for particle physics
though this is cold enough and the final
hadron switches take place fixing the
numbers of protons and neutrons for the
rest of time it is well known that
protons and neutrons differ in their
overall charge protons are positively
charged while neutrons carry no charge
at all but less famous is their
minuscule differences in mass
neutrons are about 0.1 percent heavier
than protons a difference that is
scarcely noteworthy in modern-day
chemistry but which proves fundamental
to shaping the cosmos one second after
the big bang
the greek myth of sisyphus tells us that
it is far easier for a rock to roll
downhill than it is to push it back to
the top
and in our universe every phenomenon
seeks the lowest possible energy level
so reactions that reduce and release
their energy will always be favored over
those that need energy input
thus in the identity switch between
protons and neutrons the reaction would
tend to fall in the easiest direction
from heavier particle to lighter one
from neutron
to proton
as the free energy of the universe drops
there is less opportunity to push things
back in the other direction and the
hadron equilibrium shifts in favor of
the proton
by the time the freeze-out is complete
protons outnumber neutrons six to one
and even after the freeze-out the
heavier energy-rich neutrons are still
not safe lightweight protons on their
own are stable but isolated neutrons
will spontaneously decay back into
proton and electron after just 15
minutes or so had things continued this
way there would be no neutrons left in
the cosmos today
fortunately for us this was not their
fate
many neutrons found refuge from
impending doom by the simple act of
binding with a proton combined with its
lighter kin they could hold decay at bay
indefinitely and in doing so formed the
very first composite atomic nuclei
one proton and one neutron locked
together by the same gluons that hold
together their constituent quarks the
result is the nucleus of so-called heavy
hydrogen
deuterium before long much of the
deuterium is paired together too to make
what we recognize today
as helium
and therefore the helium we find today
is both the safe haven and protective
prison for every neutron left adrift
after the cosmic freeze-out
its abundance in the universe was
ultimately set by the balance of protons
and neutrons which owes its tilt to the
tiniest of mass differences between the
tiniest of fundamental particles
[Music]
scientists don't know why the scales
fell in that particular direction they
have no good explanation for why the
proton should be intrinsically lighter
than its uncharged sibling it seems to
be one of those universal phenomena that
just
is set by a roll of the dice when the
first fundamental matter emerged
things potentially could have just as
easily fallen differently with protons
very slightly outweighing neutrons
instead of the other way around
the difference may be trivial but the
consequences are astounding
if protons were the heavier sibling then
neutrons would have outnumbered them at
the end of the one-second freeze-out
left alone the proton would decay back
into a neutron although some could be
saved by combining with a neutron
forming as we saw in our reality a
helium nucleus but helium is famously
inert the real fuel for the cosmos is
hydrogen whose nucleus consists of a
single proton in an alternate reality
where protons were heavier and more
unstable none could persist long enough
to form hydrogen unbound neutrons would
be stable but being uncharged there is
no hydrogen equivalent they could form
after one second the universe would be
filled with only unreactive neutrons and
unreactive helium
with only these ingredients it is hard
to see how a universe like ours could
possibly evolve
no stellar fusion no stars no supernovae
seeding the cosmos with heavier elements
no planets no water no organic life
no us
it would be a poor cold and barren
universe with helium alone
so we may bemoan the paucity of helium
on earth and stare longingly at its
richness in the universe
but there can be too much of a good
thing
the chance conditions that shape the
cosmological freeze-outs seemed like so
many of our universe's starting points
to be tuned just right
the tiniest inexplicable mass difference
having the capacity to create complex
sentient life
or
to create
nothing
at all
scientists and philosophers are still
trying to understand how we ended up so
lucky but the simple fact may be that
our universe is a statistical fluke roll
a dice enough times and you will happen
upon the results you need eventually
the rest the failed attempts produce
baron alternate universes in a vast
possible multiverse where no stars could
shine and no life could evolve to
contemplate its unlucky fate
and so one second after the big bang
there is huge potential in our nascent
material universe
protons and neutrons form hydrogen and
helium nuclei in a proportion determined
by the tiniest inexplicable mass
difference and in doing so mark the
beginning of a much more standard and
understandable cosmology
most of these primordial elements will
find themselves pulled together into
stars crushed and fused into heavier
elements and exploded back out
each primordial hadron is reconfigured
and reused time and time again building
stars planets and eventually
us
our cosmos will evolve along a path that
has been laid by events during this
first
fleeting eon
a few small pockets however
escape this fate
their light reaches us as the relic
clouds near the constellation of leo
from the summit of mauna kea we can
catch a glimpse of a small window on the
cosmos
not only two billion years after its
creation
but also stretching back to that very
first second
when the ingredients to make a universe
were already
in place
you've been watching the entire history
of the universe don't forget to like and
subscribe and leave a comment to tell us
what you think
thanks for watching and we'll see you
next time
[Music]